it feels as if attitudes in the uk and
elsewhere towards
china are changing quite rapidly is that
your
reading the situation yes i think that's
definitely
where we are at the moment we're looking
really at a
reset of the whole of our relationship
with the chinese leadership
why do you think that reset is important
well it's a complex relationship
because they are important
international partners they're important
trading partners
but at the same time they're clearly
becoming
more aggressive internationally
and there are so many aspects
of the relationship now where we're in
direct rivalry
with a former partner and a trading
partner who will
continue to be important to us so it's
finding
the right balance and i think being more
assertive in in our opinion
as to how we you know should conduct our
dealings with the chinese leadership
i mean one way to be more assertive of
course would be the decision over huawei
do you think that boris johnson is going
to revisit his decision
to allow huawei a limited role in the
uk's 5g network
5g network uh that's certainly my
expectation
i mean i don't have any direct sort of
inside knowledge but i think
i'm one of the individuals who's been
pressing very hard
for huawei to be excluded from the uk's
5g the problem is
that you know we've had a close
relationship with huawei
dating back i think to nearly the year
so getting huawei out of the systems
it can't be done rapidly it'll have to
be done cumulatively
over time but uh
it looks to me now as though the
government
have changed their view i mean
there's a technical aspect to this
because since
the um american embargo on huawei was
imposed
it's not clear that they're going to be
able anyway
to provide the 5g equipment um
you know on which the system would
depend
but i i mean i've always believed that
there is also a strategic
security reason for not allowing the
chinese that degree
of involvement in the construction of
our critical infrastructure
i mean huawei would argue that there are
you know one of the most scrutinized
companies
in the world over this uh and as you say
they are quite linked already with us
there are concerns that it could lead to
issues with providing mobile phone
coverage if we
cut them out with a 5g network because
it's more about anti-china sentiment
after coronavirus and less about what's
good for the country
i think it's just good security sense in
terms of our
future uh dependence on 5g
i think the relationship between the
chinese state and huawei
is absolutely clear-cut
huawei is not a sort of ordinary
international telecommunications company
it's an intimate part of
the chinese state and
if you know anything about you know
chinese military strategy
they talk about the fusion of civil and
military capabilities
and there is a close linkage undoubtedly
between
the chinese military capability and
huawei
the mail on sunday is reporting this
morning uh
that there are fears amongst ministers
that china could actually launch a cyber
attack on the uk
similar to one that believed to have
happened in australia recently how much
of a threat do you think that is
well it's a very aggressive step for the
chinese
to take at this point in time and
you know i wonder whether they would as
it were go that far
at the moment but of course it is a
threat
they have a significant capability in
this area
and they can probably do it
in a manner where although we probably
know who the culprit is
they can say that the uh you know that
they can make it deniable and and say
well
you know it wasn't us but i mean it yes
of course it's a threat um and it's
i think we we you know we've
known quite significantly that the
chinese have developed this capability
and are prepared to use it
um talking about uh global powers russia
of course
is another uh state that we have a
slightly uh fractious relationship shall
we say uh tomorrow
mps are going to be voting on the makeup
of the intelligence and security
committee which should allow of course
that long-awaited
report into alleged russian interference
in uk politics to be published
do you think that russian interference
in our democracy is a serious threat
um i don't think it's a sufficient
threat for us as it were to
worry about you know the end result
of a democratic vote being changed or
diverted
but on the other hand there
is ample evidence that you know the
russians use
their capability to meddle
in other countries affairs and
i mean it's sort of fundamentally i
would say in the dna of the russian
state they almost can't help themselves
and if they feel that they have an
interest in doing that they're going to
do it and we've seen
this happen in a number of countries
particularly
those you know which are close close
neighbors of
of the russians i mean like uh the
baltic republics or
in you in ukraine
i just wonder um you know we've been
talking about china's
involvement in 5g in the uk talking
there about russia and of course
remember that foreign affairs committee
report back in 2018 saying president
putin
and his allies have been effectively
hiding and laundering their assets in
london
for years and do you think we have been
a bit naive
in allowing these dangerous states i
guess
influence over the united kingdom in the
past
well i think we took a rather lax
attitude
to some of these issues maybe
on the basis that we hoped they were
i mean china and russia are going to
evolve in a different direction
and those are the judgments that were
made in the past i mean i think we were
very lacks uh particularly on the issue
of
russian money uh in the city of london
um attitudes on that have changed
um similarly you know embracing china as
enthusiastically
as we did i think it was based on the
expectation that you know china would
evolve
as an easier international partner which
under xi jinping it has not done
so we now see particularly in relation
to
an issue like hong kong you know the
true nature of the
leadership that we're dealing with of
course
our relationship with the united states
is another key uh relationship
for the united kingdom on the world
stage when we last uh spoke
in october 2018 you said this about
donald trump
he says extraordinary things he clearly
behaves unpredictably
i was going to say he needs babysitting
do you think donald trump needs
babysitting and would it be in the uk's
interest for him to lose the
presidential election
this year uh
well i think the uk basically is
probably in a win-win situation
uh with the u.s presidential election
i mean if biden wins i think we we have
a good partner
and trump is difficult
he is unpredictable but on the other
hand he obviously thinks
highly of the us's relationship with the
uk
i think biden probably globally
you know will be seen as a much easier
president to work with
but for the uk specific interest
i don't think it's going to make
initially a great deal of difference
i mean the alliance between the united
states
and the united kingdom is important to
the united states particularly in the
sort of global situation that we've got
evolving
at the moment so i think either way
we're in a relatively well
we're in a strong position it's a very
optimistic
uh answer from you um president trump
has also called for the
extradition of christopher steele uh the
former mi6
agent who alleged those links between
his presidential campaign and russia
what do you make of that
um sorry i didn't hear the first part of
the question uh
donald trump has called for the
extradition of christopher steele what
do you make of that
ah well um
i mean clearly this is an issue which
is all has almost become personal
in relation to what steele's
original report said about trump and i
think it's you know one of those
areas where i would describe trump's
reaction is extravagant uh
and i mean more of a threat than an
actuality i don't think it's
anything's gonna this is gonna stay in
the forefront
of the news but it it it's not gonna
change the relationship between the uk
and the united states
okay that definitely makes sense then
just finally
in the interview that we did in 2018 we
also spoke about jeremy corbyn
who was then leader of the labour party
you said you were troubled by his past
associations
are you pleased that he's no longer
leader of the opposition and what do you
make of kierstama
well i'm certainly pleased that corbyn's
got and i think my
strong personal views about corbyn as a
potential prime minister of well-known
and well-understood
uh it's a relief that uh he's no longer
leader of the labour party
uh on kyostama he seems to me
to be a labor leader of the type
that we would expect
and personally i feel quite content
and happy with the fact that he's now
leading the labor party i may not
support him politically
but i don't see a repetition of the sort
of problems that we had
with jeremy corbyn in fact not at all